Chloe we're back again revenge bod this
season feels more emotional than ever in
a good way but what is it like for you
to take people on these intense
emotional journeys you know I feel
really honored that people are trusting
me with this journey because I get what
it's like to be on camera and to be
working out and doing all that in front
of the camera but I don't think the
average person really realizes how
vulnerable and how kind of aggressive we
are and their face is filming and when
you're on this journey it is you have to
be really vulnerable and it's emotional
and really really hard and there's days
that you don't want to work out and if
you really are like wait I'm sweating a
red rose I don't be on camera like this
and people I don't think really realize
what they're getting into
so I'm since I've been on this journey I
can be really sensitive to it as well
but I do I really feel very honored and
I hope try to hold their stories with
like the highest respect and care as
possible this show is called revenge
body but that's more just like a play on
words let's grab people's attention but
it's so much mind body and soul so I
mean I'm really I am honored that you
shared that with me I really am and I'm
proud of you no thank you
well you guys know what it's like to
live your lives on camera we do we do I
think you started filming not too long
after having true yeah what's it been
like for you to see your your post-baby
body on camera to be on that journey
what's your relationship with your body
like now well I am
I think the first episode is me doing
there's a little bit of kind of
following my journey and that but it's
funny because seeing at the beginning of
all the episodes I have my sit down with
them and I'm a little bigger because it
was closest to when I just had true and
then at the end there reveals you kind
of see my reveals - even though it's not
about me but oh my god it looks so much
skinnier cuz you're working at the same
time right and it's that's interesting
to see but I'm I felt really good right
after true - I was really proud of
myself how I thought I would be a little
more insecure because I worked so hard
to get my body before I got pregnant and
I what I felt really good I think I have
to have a baby you just feel empowered
and just the fact that you're now able
to juggle a child working out
and work I think that's an
accomplishment so I felt really glad
that I found my groove and that I was
trying when you talk in the trailer
about this season being about
transforming not just body but soul and
mind where are you at for yourself on
that mind soul journey right now um I
really think I'm in a good place but I
think working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever mission and I always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people while the world is changing
around us we should adapt to that too
but always remember to be kind and just
courteous of what's happening around you
too so I don't ever want that to change
by the way we heard that Rob might be
getting back in the gym and we get Rob
on revenge bod house robbed
I know Rob's doing great he really is
and you know he's been working out a
couple ago so Ken he goes to Kim's he's
worked out for like the past five days
or so and he's kicking ass and I just
want Rob to do what's best for him and
what makes him happy and if that makes
him happy then we will all support him I
love it we got asked you deal with the
haters because people come for you they
say like you're changing your photos
things are fake how do you do good you
just have to deal with it it is what it
is I don't take it too seriously cuz god
only knows if I looked at their photos
what they look like in real life
Instagram and so Kris for a reason but I
have to use them I also don't care like
it is what it is so in your face I have
their beautiful and I gotta say I mean
sitting here and also on this show you
look better than ever
oh thank you Kardashian have a little
bit of a revenge body now like how you
feeling I feel like yeah yeah I mean
klore you dating no I'm not dating right
now but I mean I love life besides you
sorry sorry we're on a date alright but
um I just I'm really just enjoying my
life and my time with my baby and family
and I don't want her to do why not she
doesn't need her right now no no I I'm
I'm so fine not dating where I know it's
nothing if you think about it in the
future do you know what kind of guy you
would want down the road what you need I
don't and
Scott I don't what I've never really put
that much pressure on dating I'm just
you know whoever you are in a room with
that you connect with and there's
chemistry then that's you should date
but I'm just not even in that headspace
but you never know what will happen yeah
just taking time off yeah we got to ask
you oh we did see part one have another
little show you guys are on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians we saw some of the
finale what is it like for you to watch
that back to relive that really tough
time that you went through no no but
don't say you didn't do something that
you think did when you both you told me
you I personally don't watch it back
because I just I already know what
happens and it it's just I think a
little too toxic for me to keep reliving
stuff like that so I stay off social I
don't I didn't watch it and it's just a
part of our job that we kind of have to
do so we can't just pick and choose what
we want to show that's not fair and so
that's just what it is well Scott I
liked you really defended khlo you were
like oh yeah what was going through your
mind are you upset for her what did you
want to happen for her during all that
well the truth of the matter was I think
a lot of people started getting too
caught up and the negative side of
things what an actuality the only thing
that really matters is Khloe and our
baby true and that's it nothing else and
all support should be going for her and
how she feels and that's it this has
happened to a million people in the
world let's just figure out how to get
Khloe through it not figure out how to
get any negativity in it and I just
think it
she's what matters her babies what
matters I don't think we're feeling okay
that passion either side it's just not
cool for me about anybody I don't think
there needs to be negativity on anywhere
I think it's just a story that's being
told but anybody picking aside or you
know condemning any human I think this
is a part of life I'm not saying it was
yeah but there's way too many people
that thing got involved
yeah then felt like it was their story
and felt like they need
let's just focus on what's real and
what's happening because all these other
things aren't gonna change and they're
not gonna help anything I love this side
of Scott yes Scott yeah supportive Scott
Scott so your show
flipping it like Disick I'm flipping one
giorious any celebs you want to get your
hands on with their houses in particular
no so the truth of the matter is
initially you know when I started buying
and selling real estate you know my
biggest thing was I saw a house and I
could definitely see potential so I said
you know I got a start just putting my
money into these things and buying and
selling houses so within that my goal
was to become a developer and move on
you know from property to property and
go bigger bigger bigger and bigger but
within that time people started thinking
that I renovate homes as well so now I
have millions of people that are friends
or family that are like hey by the way
you know I need a new kitchen can you
flip me I love it you know my my passion
is really developing properties and
reselling okay flipping but now I'll be
honest there's probably a big business
for just renovations and it might have
to be you know a team that I have that
can be in place to do that because
that's not exactly where I was going
well we see Kourtney tell you she's
proud of you on the show yeah how does
that feel for you to hear yeah that's
great I mean I think we've been through
so much and so many things and to hear
her be proud of me means you know a ton
to me you guys are like the co-parenting
gold-standard I feel they are I don't
love the phrase when people's call what
we're doing just co-parenting it's not
like you dropped on me I dropped them to
you case closed don't speak to me yeah
we're very much on the same everything
yeah how did you get to this place with
you and Kourtney and Sophia and the kids
I saw you say on Instagram your kids are
your priority how did you get to this
good place together I think you just
gotta figure out really what's important
to you at the end of the day I mean
there's so many different things that
can pull you in different directions and
you could look online and Instagram
social meaning all these things but at
the end of the day I mean you just want
to be happy you want to be content you
want to be comfortable you want to love
you
where other level Scott it's like cardio
goes on their vacation with like it's
like this X's together thing is amazing
I'm super soft so impressed by it how do
you do it I think the real part is life
is a challenge and if you work at what
you want you can get it but it takes
hard work simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a few
minutes hard work for all parties I
think for oh no import Sofia they're all
really I'm really proud of all of them
yeah I got it I mean Courtney being your
older sister do you guys do you look to
them and kind of learn from what you
know Kourtney and Scott are doing yeah
no I think they're doing amazing and I
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you shared children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love and I'm so proud of
them and I'm so proud of them promoting
that and hopefully you know inspiring
other people that it's a beautiful thing
to get along with each other and for
your kids to see that
[Music]